you lost 75 lbs my height I was over 295
I quit counting and then at my lowest I
was like 2 211 to 12 I love you quick
counting you're like listen I can't
watch it get to three my sister said you
you're walking like a fat
person you get two or three you know
yeah explain that I like that I like
that if you want to be if you want to
drink I love to drink and you want to
eat then you got to work out and you
can't smoke you you can't you can't be
fat drink and smoke so you're giving
you're giv the two out of three you can
do yeah you want you want you want to
drink and smoke then don't be
fat yeah you can't be fat and smoke
that's that's that's it yeah yeah you
got you like penalties off setting yeah
yeah